[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo avance de
noticias en france 24 los líderes
europeos se reúnen a esta hora en
bruselas en una cumbre en la que
discutirán la posible reunión entre la
unión europea y rusia- esta propuesta de
francia y alemania- fue acogida de
manera positiva por moscú que afirmó que
es realmente necesaria aunque países
como letonia la ven problemática y dicen
que el diálogo tiene que costarle algo a
rusia también entre otros temas se
tratará la tensión creada por la ley
aprobada en hungría que supone un
retroceso de los derechos de la
comunidad lgtb de nuestra corresponsal
en la capital europea esther herrera con
más detalles de la que podría ser la
última reunión a la que angela merkel
asista como canciller de alemania
la polémica ley húngara que discrimina a
las personas de la comunidad lgtb y está
provocando una cascada de reacciones en
contra por parte de varios países
europeos algo que podría tensionar las
discusiones en la reunión de jefes de
estado de gobierno que se produce hoy en
bruselas casi una veintena de países ha
firmado una carta en contra de esta ley
de hecho la comisión europea ya está
estudiando posibles medidas y la
presidenta de la comisión europea o se
la font der leyen ha tachado la ley de
vergonzosa esta cuestión se va a abordar
en la reunión de líderes europeos para
incomodidad del primer ministro del país
viktor orbán que han recomendado a sus
colegas que primero se lean la ley y que
después reaccionen también se va a
hablar de rusia sobre cómo mejorar las
relaciones con el kremlin a petición de
alemania y de francia se podría estudiar
una posible reunión entre la unión
europea y vladimir putin algo que no ha
gustado a muchos países europeos también
se va a hablar de migración
especialmente sobre cómo mejorar la
cooperación con países como turquía ya
se está estudiando ofrecer 3
millones de euros más para que mantenga
la acogida de refugiados en su país la
pandemia de koi 19 sigue causando
estragos en áfrica según el director del
centro para la prevención y control de
las enfermedades en el continente áfrica
no está ganándole la batalla al virus
según jon que en gas son los países no
están logrando acceder a las vacunas
necesarias para su población y afirmó
que no importa de dónde vengan las dosis
sino que lleguen rápido la directora
regional de la oms advierte que faltan
cientos de millones de dosis para que
áfrica consiga inocular al 30 por ciento
de los habitantes antes de que acabe
2021 hasta ahora sólo el 1 12% de los
africanos ha recibido la pauta completa
la vacunación south beach para cumplir
los objetivos de la o ms para vacunar
plenamente al 10% de la población del
continente
hacen falta 250 millones de dosis
adicionales y para alcanzar el 30 por
ciento para final de año
áfrica necesita unas 700 millones de
dosis adicionales así que ese es el
nivel de necesidad en áfrica
form áfrica y en europa aumenta la
preocupación por la presencia de la
variante delta en el continente después
de que la cancillera alemana angela
merkel advirtiera de que su país y el
continente aún caminan sobre una fina
capa de hielo alemania pidió que se
refuercen las restricciones y normas de
viaje entre países de la unión europea
ante el auge de la variante detectada en
india y que según el centro europeo para
el control y la prevención de
enfermedades supondrá el 90 por ciento
de todos los contagios en el bloque
comunitario para a finales de agosto
y finalizamos en hong kong donde cientos
de personas hicieron fila hoy jueves
para conseguir los últimos ejemplares
publicados de la pool daily el único
diario pro democrático de hong kong con
la mente puesta en mantener viva la
libertad de prensa la población esperaba
para hacerse con una copia del millón
que imprimió el diario diez veces más de
lo habitual hace una semana las fuerzas
de seguridad congelaron las cuentas de
la pool de eli y detuvieron a sus ex
directivos acusados de confabular con
fuerzas extranjeras un delito tipificado
en la ley de seguridad nacional que
china impuso en el territorio hace casi
un año un día que viven con tristeza y
frustración muchos de los residentes de
hong kong
volvemos en minutos y ganen france24